في الاشهر الماضيه صعدت الولايات المتحده
من ضغوطها لتقييد الوصول الى تطبيق تيك
توك التطبيق الصيني الاشهر والاسرع نموا
في العالم اليوم اما السبب تهديدات امنيه
مفترضه تمس سلمه البيانات الشخصيه
للمواطنين وتعرض الامن القومي للخطر
التطبيق يتحكم بالخوارزميات ويصل الى كل
البيانات يجمعها ويتجسس علينا بطريقه
تقليديه وهذا يقلقنا بشكل خاص لان للصين
اكبر برنامج قرصنه في العالم اكبر من دول
العالم مجتمعه
في فبراير الماضي او عزا البيت الابيض الى
الوكالات الفيدراليه قرار حظري وازاله
التطبيق عن جميع الهواتف والاجهزه التي
تصدرها الحكومه الفيدراليه للعاملين معها
ومع بدايه مارس ايادات اللجان في الكونجرس
هذه الخطوات الى حد الوصول لمطالبه واشنطن
الشركه المالكه للتطبيق ببيع حصتها في
النسخه الامريكيه من التطبيق او مواجهه
قرار الحظر جهه محدده نحن في خصام معها
ولدينا كل هذه القضايا التي نختلف عليها
تمتلك اداه تواصل اجتماعي قادره على جمع
كل هذه المعلومات عنا
شركه تيك توك تحاول التعاون لتهدئه مخاوف
الامن القومي الامريكي وتؤكد على مواصله
الاستثمار في جهود امن البيانات مثل مشروع
تكساس لفصل التطبيق في الولايات المتحده
عن ذراعه الصيني هذا هو المشهد في واشنطن
ماذا عن لندن التي اعربت عن تخوفات مماثله
بعد اسابيع من التكهنات حدث بريطانيا حذو
الولايات المتحده واوروبا في حظر تطبيق
تيك توك من اجهزه المؤسسات الحكوميه
مسؤولون التطبيق الصيني الذي تدار اعماله
من هذا المبنى هنا في بريطانيا حاولت
طمانه لندن لكنها فشلت في كسب ثقتهم
المخاوف هنا امنيه حيث تخشى بريطانيا من
تسريب معلومات حساسه وخاصه بالحكومه الى
الاستخبارات الصينيه
سوف نحضر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك على هواتف
الحكومه وسنشرع في تطبيق هذا حالا
ورغم نفي التطبيق اطلاعه الحكومه الصينيه
على بيانات المستخدمين الا ان قوانين
الاستخبارات الصينيه تلزم الشركات بمساعده
الحزب الشيوعي الحاكم عند الطلب
اعتقد ان تيك توك يشكل معضله لانه سبق وان
تسبب بانتهاكات امنيه في بلدان اخرى سواء
من خلال استخدام التطبيق في التحريض او
استغلاله لخلق خوارزميات معينه
بريطانيا تطبيق تيك توك على هواتف موظفيها
ياتي من ضمن عده تدابير اتخذت مؤخرا لرسم
سياسه تجاه الصين والتي اعادت التاكيد على
الوقوف الى جانب حلفائها في مواجهه ما
تعتبره توسع النفوذ الصيني من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه